i was at home in australia in lockdown
and then got the um
got the email that apparently rihanna
wanted me to be in the in the show yeah
it was just insane it felt i mean i love
her i think everyone knows that and um
have loved her for the longest time so
um yeah i was just really really excited
and wanted to get to america as soon as
i possibly could it's more than a
fashion show and it's it's about so much
and i think you know someone who's
obviously struggled with my sexuality
when i was younger and started with body
image stuff later in life it's like i
think it's
so so so important and it's just cool
for everyone to be able to get together
and feel really hot and feel really cool
and yeah just to kind of like celebrate
that humanity is is really nice it can
either make you like panic and feel
super vulnerable or you can kind of take
power from that and be really empowered
and um i feel really empowered in this
so yeah it's cool i think when i'm
performing yeah like when i'm filming a
music video that's when i feel the most
like powerful i think because it's just
it's a fantasy to me still you know that
any of this is happening and so to be
able to kind of like embody that and and
share that with people at a show
and kind of feel that energy yeah that's
when i feel my best
[Music]
i'm so excited i was in lockdown in
australia literally like three days ago
so to go from zero to 100 like this it's
just like the coolest thing ever very
very proud to be a part of it yeah it's
been tough because like i literally
couldn't leave my house so it was nice
to kind of get in touch with like i kind
of felt like a kid again as far as just
spending a lot of time in my room
thinking and and making stuff on my own
you know to the best of my abilities
and it reminded me how much i love
making stuff and how much i love what i
do and now i've got this like renewed
energy to be out in the world and be
um i just feel really lucky to be able
to meet all these people and create all
of this stuff with with them